Please welcome our wildflower and my hero,
Jocelyn Camarillo.
(audience applauding)
Have you ever gotten your nose broken?
No, I don't think so, no. (laughing)
Do you worry about something like that?
No, of course not. (chuckles)
How are you not afraid?
Well, growing up, boxing has always been on our TV.
Me and my family would get together,
and we'd watch the boxing fights.
And I specifically remember watching
the Manny Pacquiao fight versus Mayweather.
Yes.
And we were all just going crazy watching this fight.
It was really entertaining.
And I think that's when it inspired me to wanna try boxing.
I mean, I've seen things that inspired me too.
It didn't mean I went into a life of it.
(audience and Jocelyn laughing)
How would you find the bravery to get in there
and not be afraid, vain about your face,
bold and be petite
(Jocelyn laughing)
and take on a man?!
I know it's a...
Everything, I think, sometimes in our instincts,
how are your instincts?
The way they are? Why are my instincts run?
And your instincts are go in?
I don't know.
I guess, well, going in, I was very intimidated.
You know, I was going into this boxing gym
where I was surrounded by the most big muscular guys.
And I was this 13-year old, petite,
you know, little 5'1" girl going to the gym.
So it was very intimidating at first,
but, you know, I just stayed dedicated
and stayed focused and kept training.
And I know I proved that I do belong in the boxing gym.
I mean,
(audience applauding)
you proved it all right, you won!
(Jocelyn laughing)
(audience applauding)
And when someone came to you and said,
"Okay, you're gonna fight men and women,"
or was that your decision?
How does something like that come about?
Because that isn't the way I feel like as a sports,
you know, nonaficionado,
that is not the way I see it being done.
How did you change that?
Well, there's not a lot of girls at my gym,
and there's peer guys.
So, I mean, it's tough finding sparring,
especially for girls,
so sometimes you have to just spar guys.
But I don't mind.
I mean, they made me who I am today, and they made me tough.
And you know, when I do spar girls, it's a lot easier
'cause guys are typically more stronger than girls.
I mean, what would you say to people
who wanna also watch things in this world
and be inspired and get into the action, but are afraid?
One thing I would say to them is just, you know
if you have a goal, no matter how big it is,
just keep working hard and stay dedicated.
(audience applauding)
What about like dating?
Do you ever like,
(Jocelyn laughing)
"This is what I do"?
What are the reactions?
Well, they're typically shocked, you know,
'cause they're like, "Oh you do boxing?"
And I'm like, "Yeah."
So they're like,
"Oh I guess, so you're gonna have to be protecting me."
And I'm like, "Yeah." (laughing)
But yeah, I kind of like that though that, you know
I can show 'em that I am tough, and I can protect myself.
(audience applauding)
Okay, will you show me some moves?
Yes, of course, let's do it.
You know, just 'cause I'm still in my boxing outfit.
(Jocelyn laughing)
Okay, are you (chuckles) right-handed or?
I'm a rightie.
Okay, so you're gonna put your dominant foot back.
Is that my right foot?
Yeah, your right foot back, left foot forward.
Keeping our hands up to protect our face.
Let's go, left hand one.
(glove whacks)
(Jocelyn chuckles)
Right hand two.
(glove whacks)
Left hook three.
(Jocelyn laughing)
(Jocelyn screams)
(audience applauding)
Good.
She's got power. She's got power.
(Jocelyn laughing)
(audience applauding)
Okay, well, that....
Thank you, Kyle.
(Jocelyn laughing)
(glove whacks)
(audience applauding)
Well, we had a special wildflower robe
made just for you from us.
Aw.
A little something to wrap yourself up in
after a long day.
Oh, thank you.
(Jocelyn laughing)
(audience laughing)
Thank you. Agh!
Thank you, my love. Thank you so much
Here.
(audience applauding)
Aww.
It's just
(audience applauding)
a little something-
Let me take the gloves off.
To make you...
Thank you so much.
What's your favorite thing to do when you're not boxing?
Sleep. (laughing)
(audience laughing)
Sleep and watch all the movies.
What movies?
"50 First Dates."
Really?
(audience applauding)
I love that movie. I love that move. (laughing)
Well, Jocelyn, you're just so cool.
And I so glad that you embody
what we wanna talk about with wildflowers.
It is the Pippi Longstockings.
It is the true fierce spirits out there
who are just doing things that make us all marvel
and believe in ourselves
and be excited to cheer someone on
who is being so brave and cool and rad.
(Jocelyn laughing)
Yeah, thank you so much for this opportunity.
Thank you.
Thank you, Jocelyn, so much.
(Jocelyn laughing)
(audience applauding)
You are such an inspiration
to so many young woman.
And we can't wait to keep you cheering you on.
Oh, thank you.
(upbeat music)